I want to have a chat to you guys about
how my week when so I had a really
productive week and something has been
on my mind specifically what it is that
made this week so productive because my
productivity is is like a sine wave it's
something that was incredibly nerdy my
productivity is very variable it's very
up-and-down it's just sort of one week
it'll be fantastic I'll get a lot of
stuff done I'll be very motivated I will
I will love my work and then the next
week it can be a complete train wreck
where I just literally do barely any
work and play Minecraft all day and just
now as someone who goes through phases
like that quite often and then usually
writes them off to just oh well I'm
working from home or I've had a really
rough week or I'm not feeling too well
or any number of other excuses this week
where I've just been on a honor roll
making these videos like my fourth video
this week and I think the third one in a
row you know I sat down and I thought
about why exactly why exactly this week
went so well for me and what I did
differently and really the thing that I
owe it all true is what I like to call
the concept of just do it there are
always going to be excuses that you can
come up with always I for one love
coming up with excuses for why I don't
want to do this or that I feel like I'm
getting better at it but it's still
something that has been a part of my
life it's very easy to fall into this
trap of just constantly coming up with
excuses for why you're not realizing
your dream or your bowls or why you're
not working on a project or implementing
a feature or creating a video that
you've always wanted to maybe you're not
ready yet maybe you just feel like if
you did a little bit more research or if
you were a little bit smarter then
you'll be able to do it better and so
because of that you're just you're not
doing it yet maybe you realize that it's
just too much work and it's hard for you
to break it down into small manageable
chunks and you end up not doing anything
well guess what done is better than
perfect this is something that a lot of
people
have said in the past but it is so so so
true for years with this channel that
I've had just based around programming
I've constantly had these certain
expectations that I have to meet I can't
write this code I can't release this
feature in this current state people are
going to want to expect it to be the
perfect implementation the fastest
implementation the most efficient
implementation I hate all of that and I
am completely against all of that I
think this whole done is better than
perfect mentality is so important for
software engineering you're not going to
write the perfect code as soon as you
dive in and start writing your code it's
just not gonna work that way you're
going to have to iterate over what
you've done just sit down and start
writing slow terrible code if that's all
you know how to do right now do it if
you continually just put off writing any
code for a specific system because you
don't know how to write that system
you're not gonna get anywhere when I
first started programming and I still
think one of the reasons why I learnt
the initial kind of basics of game
programming and programming in general
so quickly was because I I was just I
was like 16 17 years old I had just
started programming I had no idea how
anything worked in terms of like how how
game systems were implemented but I
didn't care I was sitting in English
class I had my laptop I had Java and I
was just like you know what I'm going to
try and make this kind of game or I'm
gonna try and implement this feature and
using the very small amount of
experience and knowledge that I'd had I
sat down and I just I worked out how to
do it using that subset of skills and
that's something that I feel is really
lost nowadays you see all these people
on the internet putting up amazing
looking you know demo isn't like amazing
like feeling games or like incredible
renders of like their own art or
whatever and you just think wow like I
can't compete with that you know I have
to you know they went to college for
like three years or they've worked for
five years in the games industry I can't
do that right now wrong just do it man
stop comparing yourself to other people
stop carrying what
other people think of you just do it
because guess what if you can just make
this thing that you want to make and
it's on the screen and it's there You've
you've already beaten all other
expectations that you would never finish
it or that you can't do it because
you've done it sure it might not run in
one millisecond maybe it runs the ten
milliseconds but guess what that's still
fine and the thing is now that you've
implemented that you've got something on
the screen you can iterate over that you
can go back and you can work out how to
do it faster but you've done it you can
show people and you can it's amazing so
anyway what I did this week was I didn't
let myself kind of make excuses for ah I
should probably maybe think about this
video a little bit more before I do it I
should probably plan it a little bit
more I should probably you know I've got
these other things that I have to do I
can't make this video no I just said you
know what stop it you're gonna sit down
you're gonna hit record on the camera
and you're just going to make this video
and the amazing thing is once you start
doing it it just it all just comes to
you trust me you guys have no idea how
often I put off making videos if if
every time I was like oh man I want to
make a video if I actually made a video
every time I had a feeling of making a
video before I started doubting myself
for doing all that stuff you guys would
probably be getting like two videos a
day honestly and that's a huge thing for
me that I've been working on and that I
really want to improve going forward
this whole aspect of you know if you
kind of just actually do the work
instead of thinking that you're not good
enough or that you need to do XYZ before
you actually get up to the ability to do
a certain task that's going to go a long
way anyway what's up guys my name is the
Cherno welcome back to another one of
these like hazel dev vlog slash random
vlog Amanda's channel is really going
down here I thought about these videos
as a whole and thought that it would be
cool for these weekly vlogs to actually
have some kind of theme or some kind of
thought or maybe even like revolve
around a question from you guys
something like that that we could
discuss instead of just you know showing
you guys what I've done with
throughout the week because sometimes
there's not much to show and sometimes I
think it would be really cool to connect
a little bit closer with the community
and find out what you guys are up to as
well but to be honest I have had a
pretty productive week over the past
couple days I have been working on
implementing like Mouse picking into
hazel so that we can basically just
click on different objects in our scene
I'll show you guys what that looks like
in a minute I honestly have been really
motivated this week which i think is is
good and part of the reason I think is
that you know Hazel's finally getting to
the point where you know instead of just
laying foundational kind of boring stuff
I'm actually able to potentially start
using it very soon to actually make
stuff and it's kind of well basically
it's just gotten more fun and then on
the flip side with the actual game
engine series and and all that stuff you
know we're getting to the point where
people have started making a lot of
content for hazel which is really cool
and now I'm working on this little game
for hazel as well there's part of the
game engine series there's just so much
fun stuff going around very exciting
times but anyway without further ado
let's jump in and take a look at what
I've done in hazel this week so inside
our test scene and we kind of talked
about this last time a little bit with
the materials and all the other stuff
that I added to kind of create some sort
of workflow between blender or any 3d
modeling program really and hazel this
current scene as I showed you guys we
have kind of two two things that make up
the scene we have this kind of test
entity and there's no real entity
component system in hazel yet that's one
of the biggest next steps that I'm
actually going to take but at the moment
we have this gun entity which is this
animated mesh that we have here is just
a very basic test and we're just testing
animation as well as being able to have
multiple cord entities in the scene but
then this test entity mesh is the actual
scene what you see here and as you can
see it's made up of various sub meshes
and I think I accidentally exported the
sunlight from blend those which is why
we have Sun here as well but we have
floor cube cone sphere wall that's what
you see here being rendered as part of
our test scene now each of these are in
fact separate meshes this is the same
this is like the mesh hierarchy and they
do have various like transforms and all
of that stuff they are basically
independent objects and meshes that just
grouped into one one larger mesh and so
over the past week or really over the
past couple days what I've done is I've
made it so that you
can actually click and select various
sub meshes that make up your scene and
then manipulate them using these gizmos
so in other words I can click on the
sphere and then I can move it somewhere
else
like I can click on the corn and move it
I can scale it you know I can basically
start to create some kind of scene if I
really wanted to based off of just this
mesh that I've kind of imported here and
there's even snapping if you hold ctrl
which is kind of useful this is really
like early days and I expect to really
iterate over this probably quite a bit
but it's cool to see basically the
beginning of these these building blocks
I guess inside hazel dev if I move over
here I can move the cube somewhere else
maybe scale it up you can even rotate it
so the next real step would be to import
multiple assets because at the moment we
obviously just have the one kind of test
scene and you can load anything you want
by just clicking here and then you know
it'll open an open file dialog and you
can load any FBX in but you can only
still see one and of course you can't
really compose your scene from multiple
meshes and multiple entities so that's
kind of the biggest next step I guess in
all of this and of course if you at the
moment if you do select everything it
actually selects the entity you can see
I can like scale it up and down and like
rotate it and all that and then I can
obviously adjust everything from within
that kind of entity as well so we kind
of have like an entity transform and
then obviously like some kind of local
transform for each of these meshes
within that other things I still need to
work on other visuals for when you
select something some other words the
kind of visual feedback you get for
what's currently selected at the moment
is just simply its bounding box which is
just a very temporary thing because we
had bounding boxes anyway but we're
gonna probably likely want some kind of
outline shader maybe something that will
just create like an outline effect over
the currently selected object a lot of
3d programs do that blender does that
unity does that we'll probably go with
something like that we can also like do
a quick like a little wireframe pulse
when you first select an object just for
visual effect that might be nice a few
different ideas here and there of course
but right now you get the bounding box
and speaking of bounding boxes if you're
interested in how this is implemented
basically we just cast array from the
mouse into 3d space and then what we do
is we basically just query all the
objects in the scene
they're bounding box so in other words
all of these sub measures have a
bounding box that's calculated when you
actually import the mesh we then check
to see if the Ray collides with any of
these bounding boxes and if it does
collide with the bounding box for let's
just say this sphere for example we pick
the closest collision as well so in
other words there's this floor behind
the sphere but since the Ray hits the
sphere first if I click on this fear
we're inside the spheres bounding box so
now we just retrieve all the triangles
that make up the sphere and we test
those with the Ray and that gives you
very very precise intersections so in
other wise you can see if I click
literally like 1 pixel off here it's
gonna select the floor but if I click
here it's gonna select the sphere so
it's extremely precise you can see it
you can see that happening right here
which is really nice now most of this
was actually written in the livestreams
that I did yesterday I actually ended up
doing two live streams one in the
morning one in the afternoon because I
really wanted to get this finished so
you guys can definitely check that out
if you have access to that through
patreon but they definitely are still
some optimizations that can be done one
of which is for example at the moment we
just get the bounding box of every
single sub mesh but it will definitely
help to have a bounding box for the
entire entity that we can check first
because if we have like a more realistic
scene made up of like a lot of different
entities in the scene then checking
every single sub mesh and the entire
scene is gonna be very slower so instead
of that we can just check the entity
bounding box first kind of early up if
if it doesn't if the Ray doesn't hit
that and then if it does hit the
entities bounding box check out the sub
mesh bounding box and if it does hit a
sub mesh then check out the triangles
but again obviously if you end up having
like a very very very detailed model
with like a million triangles and that
is gonna be quite slower so you could
just potentially use like a lower Lord
of that or something like that there's a
few different things you can do but that
is the basic idea
all right so I hope you guys enjoy that
will look into hazel Deb don't forget
that if you help support the channel and
hazel and all that stuff on patreon
account for Sasha Turner you will get
access to not only live streams the
Charmy working on this stuff you'll also
get access to all the source code for
what you see here which is hazel dev
thank you so much for your support let
me know what you guys thought of this
video love you all I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]